Whenever there is a list released of the world’s
most dangerous jobs, tree loggers, steelworkers,
electrical power-line installers, and fisherman
usually are the professions that populate
the list.
But none of those things are nearly as dangerous
as being propelled out of a long cylinder
tube, flown through the air completely untethered,
and attempting to land safely on the ground.
As you’ll soon see, when the Bureau of Labor
Statistics recently listed logging as the
most dangerous job in America at 127.8 deaths
per 100,000… well, let’s just say that’s
laughable compared to the death rates of the
human cannonballers.
The human cannonball first entered the public
consciousness in the late 19th century.
In 1871, an Englishman named George Farini
developed a mechanism he called a “projector.”
Made out of heavy springs and Indian rubber,
it was simply a platform with the springs.
It looked nothing like a cannon; but when
released, it shot the person (or whatever
was on the platform) forward.
He applied and a received a patent for his
contraption on June 13, 1871.
Two years later, in 1873, the “projector”
made it’s first appearance to the American
public (it’s unknown when/if he showed it
to an English audience) at the well-known
Broadway theatre, Niblo’s Garden, in New
York City.
Due to Farini’s own girth, he himself was
not the person who went flying into the air
that night.
Instead, “Lulu,” a petite young man dressed
in woman’s clothes who George had trained,
was the performer.
When George let go of the latch holding the
spring, Lulu shot thirty feet into the air
and grabbed the bars of trapeze hanging down
from the ceiling.
The crowd went wild.
George and Lulu were a hit and took to the
road with their circus act . By 1875, Lulu
was known as the “Queen of the Trapezists,”
but their act would be eclipsed by a new innovation
in the human projectile industry.
There are conflicting accounts of who performed
the first human cannonball act- “The Australian
Marvels” Ella Zuila and George Loyal, or
14 year old Rossa Matilda Richter, also known
as “Zazel.”
According to circushistory.org, the Aussies
first began doing their act in Sydney in 1872
with George being shot out of a large cylinder
and Ella catching him as she hung from a trapeze
bar.
Other sources claim that Zazel was the first
human cannonball when she performed the same
type of stunt in front of a live audience
at the Royal Aquarium in London in 1877.
She would later be recruited and become part
of P.T.
Barnum’s show.
But, of course, if the dates are to be believed,
Zazzle appears to have been second, contrary
to many reports.
Either way, the human cannonball thrilled
audiences.
The danger, the excitement, and the bravery
grabbed the attention of everyone watching.
The best circuses of the time, including PT
Barnum’s and Yankee Robinson Circus (where
Zuila and Loyal eventually performed their
act in America), saw this and knew it had
to become a staple of their show.
The mechanics of shooting a human from a cannon
are actually not that complicated.
In fact, the so-called “cannon” is technically
not a cannon at all.
Gunpowder, commonly found in normal cannons,
has historically never been the impetus for
the human cannonball act (though sometimes,
for dramatic effect, gunpowder is used on
the outside to give it more “visual intrigue”).
Instead, compressed air or, less often, bungee
cords are used to shoot off the living projectile.
Like any act, secretive performers are often
hesitant to reveal the exact science behind
their own mechanism, but the devices tend
to work more like a catapult or push sled.
Quite simply, someone crawls into the barrel
and compressed air pushes the platform under
them up at a force of 3,000 to 6,000 pounds
per square inch (psi) of pressure.
The platform stops at the muzzle of the cannon,
but the human inside keeps going, high into
the air.
Traveling upwards of 70 miles per hour (the
world record is 74.6 mph or 120.057 km/hr),
these human missiles can be shot to as far
200 feet away and reach an altitude of upwards
of 75 feet.
It has even been reported that human cannonballs
have been known to blackout in mid-air, due
to the extreme G-force (as much as nine times
normal gravity).
And if all of this doesn’t quite meet your
danger quota, landing is actually the most
hazardous part of being a human cannonball.
Prior to launch, the stunt men and women have
already meticulously and carefully set up
nets or inflatable targets to catch them.
Despite these targets measuring usually around
50 by 25 feet, they still are frighteningly
small to a person flying 200 feet through
the air.
Before any audience members have arrived,
the crews test these targets by placing stuffed
dummies (the same weight as their human counterpart)
into the cannon and shoot them off to see
where they land and if the target can hold
them.
They adjust accordingly.
If all the tests go well, the act proceeds
as usual.
If not, performers will cancel their performance.
Unfortunately, it’s when the tests don’t
reveal a potential flaw or when a performer
doesn’t cancel despite uncertainty that
a tragedy happens.
The late British historian, A.H. Coxe, once
estimated that of the 50 people who had made
human cannonballing their profession up to
that point, 30 died doing the act — most
due to target issues.
Others have been severely hurt.
Rossa Matilda Richter, our 14-year-old cannonball
pioneer, broke her back while working for
PT Barnum when she missed her target.
On June 8, 1987, Elvin Bale, while performing
for the Barnum & Bailey circus, overshot his
landing target due to the dummy they tested
being wet and, therefore, heavier.
He ended up paralyzed in both legs.
Others were not so lucky.
In front of two thousand spectators in 2011,
Matt Cranch was performing as a human cannonball
for the first time.
He was shot into the air and had reached approximately
40 feet high, but on the way down his netting
collapsed.
He landed head first, dying on impact.
Despite the dangers, there have been plenty
of successful and famous human cannonballs.
And, often, it was a family affair.
The Zacchini family, usually working under
a contract with Ringling Circus, became the
name in human cannonballing for most of the
20th century.
Beginning in the 1920s, five of the family’s
seven brothers took to the skies and the family
would continue to perform until the 1990s.
Brothers Victor and Hugo developed a double-barrelled
version of their act.
Brother Mario once flew over two Ferris Wheels.
Today, the biggest names in human cannonballing
belong to the Smith family, mainly David “Cannonball”
Smith and his son, David “The Bullet”
Smith Jr.
In fact, David Sr. held the world record for
longest human cannonball flight until May
2011 when his son broke it,
Hugo Zacchini, of the famous Zacchini brothers,
holds a distinction in US Supreme Court history
as well.
In 1972, Hugo was performing his act at a
county fair in Ohio when a Scripps-Howard
reporter filmed fifteen seconds of his act,
enough to capture nearly the entirety of the
launch and landing.
It was shown on the evening news, but Zacchini
sued, saying that they had no right to show
the entirety of his act, his intellectual
property, without fairly compensating him.
After the Ohio Supreme Court ruled in favor
of Scripps-Howard, Zacchini took it to the
United States Supreme Court.
In 1977, the Supreme Court ruled in favor
of Zacchini five to four with the majority
opinion reading that Zacchini not only deserved
to be compensated for the time and effort
involved in his act, but the “economic incentive
for him to make the investment required to
produce a performance of interest to
the public.”